okay I don't get exactly why but last
week a caller suggested that for Louis's
last show we bring in a durian fruit and
actually open it up this is a fruit
known for being incredibly stinky but
apparently tastes good and being spiky
and difficult to open
so producer Louis has purchased a durian
he's been defrosting it for something
like 24 hours and he's coming over now
with the durian and it it is a little
bit rank he has some plates and he's
going to attempt to uh all you've
already cut it he's bringing it in oh my
goodness that that is absolutely rancid
that is really concerned whoa
do you smell that yeah it looks like an
organ of some kind is in there uh Louis
it oh my god like that something about
this looks like the innards of an animal
I haven't there's no chance in hell I'm
going first with this I'm just letting
everybody know uh what is are those in
seeds inside of it what is that stuff
yeah um that smell is putrid is gonna
turn you into media terian off the
vegetarian die I think most of my food
experiences make me think I need to be
eating less meat this is pushing me in
the eyes okay Rachel yeah uh let's cut
to the wide shot for Rachel's first shot
cuz I don't want our audience to miss a
second of this there she goes she's
biting three four bytes for chews her
reaction is not particularly negative it
looks kind of like an omelet I wouldn't
call particularly positive you I don't I
don't know that I can even do this that
it really is a very strong smell Wow can
you describe the flavor profile Rachel
um well I don't want to ruin it for you
if you haven't taken a bite it's done it
your your opinion is going to be colored
I might think that way though it's
starting to smell like something in from
from a body shop that you would have
going to change my gut flora I think
that this might cause my DNA to be
permanently altered can you smell that
Jason from over there
I think I'm not gonna participate
I really don't uh I'm gonna try and get
some Lewis Lewis you want to bring a
piece over to the Jason first while we
discuss what's going on it kind of
tastes like rotten pineapple a little
bit it certainly smells like something
rotten that's for sure
those my initial reaction on pot you
know smelling it through the crew I
thought I thought pineapple but rotten
didn't didn't get that quite yet I might
have to leave the room guys this is not
good
Wow it this is just insane I don't know
what mine has it's really bad uh let's
go now to Jason I will narrate Jason
don't worry Jason now has it he has a
fork he is sewing it very closely in his
reaction is up got through mommy kind of
uh that bitter smell but I really like
bitter things so I feel like this might
be winter for me it'll definitely like
like a custard type texture it's like a
doesn't look like a pineapple looks more
like yeah like a custard or maybe like
an avocado or anomaly to be perfectly
honest yet does could be is Jason's
going in and he is chewing chewing
chewing chewing it is very sweet yeah
it's got that sweet little OS a fishy
but some kind of odd bitter is there if
the fruit smells like fish or tastes
like fish it's probably not a good thing
I like it
I proof it's definitely yeah it's got
that you know though the UM the
aftertaste
yeah bitterness bitterness lingers a
little bit very hard to describe it if
we switch to Rachel real quick
hers seems to be a consistency that you
really don't want can you pick pick that
up again it seems to be stretching kind
of play-doh it is like I imagine
somewhere a kid somewhere would just
love to have this on his dinner plate
and just play with it you're having
another bite and wow that's actually
pretty good
okay I'm gonna try just the smallest
bite here let me first it is this flan I
feel like Luis brought it made a flan
and brought it in under the pretense of
being a durian I made I made for funds
and hid them inside a hollow
let's see I'm starting with just licking
it come on you know full bite all in I'm
kind of getting a headache now this is
really not good I think it's good I'm
getting a headache but I'm still eating
it means just a mental hurdle this is
good okay I think I'm good guys
really yeah we're not stopping over here
where were we going for it okay I mean I
like it but this thing cost $16 so
that's the craziest part we've allocated
two more minutes for this experiment so
if anything crazy is going to happen uh
if anyone that is going to explode yeah
I'm getting a headache are you really
like that for the fruit is it causing
you to have a headache
I think is that really all good you're
having withdrawals five seconds later
it's not like a cold headache is it cuz
this thing was frozen
no no mines about room temperature now I
don't want to alarm anybody but I think
that the durian just moved just as you
poked in to move doesn't mean it's alive
um wanna survive we're all gonna be fine
this is delicious I have to say what I
mean like this what country is this
native to that's a great question
I don't know uh nowhere nowhere and uh
this continent I'm pretty sure I I see
it being in New Zealand maybe Australia
a lot of interesting fruits down there
but then why would it be so common at in
Asian markets by the way switch please
switch to Rachel she has she's eating
the entire thing yeah if it's giving you
a headache why are you going to come I
can't stop it's good is there something
about the flavor that you like and by
all means feel free to determine food
before us it's an interesting sensory
experience because you want to be right
up on that mic you're kind of having a
dissociation between kind of the
visceral and your mind oh it's a
definitely a dissociative experience and
it's and it's kind of um I don't really
have a framework of the taste this I'm
struggling to figure out the right words
to describe it while simultaneously
eating it while simultaneously getting a
headache I'm struggling too I think the
outside too
now I'm getting to a point where it's
like the inside here tastes different
and it's not as good as the outside
that's eating before so I'm gonna stop
okay yeah I think that has that mushroom
thing or has the Noli the texture the
smell but then it has this flavor that
they're all on very different planes and
yeah them coming together is art hard
experience this is certain is your pulse
doing up Rachael Gordon is taking her
pulse which generally after you try a
new food if you see someone taking their
pulse it's not the best sign not
breaking out in hives or anything should
we call an ambulance in in other news
today a girl died in talk show after
eating add area that conversation for
another time yeah well I mean this has
absolutely been fascinating and that I
think is something that I wanna say
today um yeah we will have a problem
because soon I think building management
is going to show up and have a real real
serious conversation with us about what
it is that we're doing uh Lois I I want
to let you sort of sum up this
experiment since it was I guess in some
way related to you we were we we were
seeking knowledge and uh have achieved
it and we have achieved that now we know
about durian we have clarity this
evening I enjoyed it and I uh
perhaps in the future will just stick to
trying to find a frozen pre-cut durian
yeah I would sting you once mentioned
you had a durian
freeze pop or ice cream bar Oh delicious
hey you know what guys I think I'm
getting a headache too actually yeah not
just me and I'm feeling somewhat
lightheaded wait babe are you are also
we're gonna go to break and uh yeah it's
Louis's last show and if if the medical
authorities don't show up having trouble
swallowing Donald Trump's doctor is it
psychosomatic that I'm having trouble
swallowing
I feel fine yes okay yeah well you guys
aren't inhaling all of these fumes over
here yeah well I'll move that stuff away
in a second all right we will take a
break we do have to Lois compilations
coming up later you're not going to want
to miss those